Call of Duty World War two has been
deployed for over a week now and you
might have noticed some issues with
multiplayer so has developer
sledgehammer I'm Tony and this GameSpot
News Update is getting some improvements
world war two's multiplayer launched
with dedicated servers but then had to
switch over to a p2p setup due to
problems this new system can lead to
host migration issues and other similar
gripes
however bringing dedicated servers back
to the game is sledge hammers quote
highest priority in fact they're already
being tested out in a few limited
markets right now additionally
sledgehammer has stated it also intends
to fix the game's headquarters social
space and release a new title update for
the PC version but these multiplayer
issues come first Call of Duty World War
2 is available now on ps4 Xbox one and
PC and according to sledgehammer
millions of players have already jumped
in if you're one of them and you need
some pointers we've got plenty of Call
of Duty coverage to help you out from
multiplayer tips to a guide on unlocking
the Tesla gun in zombies mode
[Music]